so the story goes there was no budget to
build the romance your Justin eat it
from the king to take as much time and
money as necessary
these aren't your standard hotel rooms
each riad is like a castle in itself a
one-bedroom suite costs $1,300 a night
three bedrooms 50,000 this is one of the
most expensive hotels in the world you
can come here and your money goes a lot
further than it would do in Europe so
you can get this five-star service for a
lot less money tourism has bounced back
in Morocco to pre-crisis levels last
year there were more than six and a half
million overnight stays in Marrakech up
ten percent on the year before most
visitors are still European but
according to the Royal manse your big
spenders they're coming from further
afield surprisingly enough since we have
opened we discovered that our clientele
is not necessarily the classical
clientele that used to come to Marrakesh
the American market the Russian markets
the Brazilian market
and now growingly the Asian the Chinese
the Japanese market is becoming one of
our leading clientele providers